during a segment on Fox News about
Democratic presidential contender Pete
Budaj edges marriage to his husband a
fox news anchor cut off contributor
Jessica Tarlov saying it's not
appropriate for you to bring up the
personal relationships of Donald Trump
and countless Fox News viewers failed to
see this incredible double standard this
was a segment about Pete Budaj edges
personal relationship during which
someone tried to bring up Trump's
personal relationship and was told it's
not okay to mention Trump's personal
relationship check this out and the
context is right-wing radio host Rush
Limbaugh's recent homophobic comments
about Pete Buddha judge will pick it up
there you will see Jessica Tarlov a Fox
News contributor bring up Trump's
relationships and it all just goes
haywire and she's told that's not okay
that's inappropriate Jessica so notice
that the Republican on the panel doesn't
want to talk about what the substance of
the criticism was which was a homophobic
comment me by Rush Limbaugh there it's
really interesting to me as someone who
is an open advocate obviously for
same-sex marriage which is now the law
of the land thankfully a lot of work
there by Joe Biden to do that but you
when you hear these criticisms from the
right and this has been consistent even
going from Bill Barr saying that
progressives are the secular left are
responsible for the moral decay of the
country and you see a loving monogamous
couple like people who judge and chaste
and his husband up there showing what is
possible that someone who is in a
same-sex relationship could be running
for president and doing this well and
then they're torn down by Rush Limbaugh
who's been married four times I think
we've Donald Trump three times married
cheated on all of those wives and you
hear it's not bringing in personal
relationships but we could we could say
exactly what it is that Rush Limbaugh
says so that it's fair in the
conversation here
let's not bring up personal
relationships says anchor Sandra Smith
is this satire is this a parody the
entire segment is about the personal
relationship of Peabody jej which became
a topic of homophobic ire for Rush
Limbaugh and Jessica Tarlov who I'm not
a particulars in the sense that I don't
know who she is she says if Rush wants
to talk about relationships
what about his three or four marriages
what about rush supporting Donald Trump
who's cheated on every spouse he's had
no no no no no let's not bring personal
relationships into this
I wish Jessica Tarlov had immediately
said guys this whole segment is about
personal relationships this entire thing
is about Pete Budaj edges personal
relationship and Rush Limbaugh's opinion
of Pete Budaj edges personal
relationship and you guys are all
hypocrites but then she maybe wouldn't
be a fox news contributor anymore and I
guess we're forgetting the real
important difference here Budaj edge is
a gay Democrat while Trump is their Lord
and Savior alpha male
Republican president that's really the
difference here and this is considered
journalism among some people people or
at least sort of smart incisive
commentary that's how far we've fallen
and as I was watching this I watched it
a couple times in preparation for
today's segment when you learn to think
critically lots of things go out them
out the window
Fox News is one of them when you learn
to think critically
astrology no longer makes sense to you
when you learn to think critically
supply-side trickle-down economics don't
make sense anymore multi-level marketing
for moms wanting to start their own
business working from home that stops
making sense when you start applying
critical thinking in your life timeshare
seminars stopped making sense when you
think critically and in this time of
hypocrisy saying you can't talk about
personal relationships during a segment
exclusively about the personal
relationship of a candidate that stops
making sense real quick when you're
thinking critically but when you're not
thinking critically this stuff
apparently makes sense to you coming up
next on Fox News a segment about
hypocrisy during which you can't mention
Donald Trump that's effectively what
we're talking about here and you all
know I'm not a Pete Budaj supporter
everybody I think who's been watching
this show for a while knows that
although I'd vote for him over Trump of
course but just imagine for a second if
on January whatever 2021 inauguration
day
imagine Pete Budaj and his husband
dancing at the inaugural ball these
people's heads would explode and that
would be something to see now it's not
enough to get me to support Buddha judge
in the primary but if he is indeed the
nominee I will vote for him and I will
look forward to the exploding heads when
he dances with Chaston at the inaugural
ball